pour démarrer Faustine la direction
vient d'annoncer le laboratoire réfarm à
Mont fermera définitivement mi-2025 s'il
n'y a pas de repreneur le groupe
pharmaceutique traverse une période
difficile depuis le recul du covid
l'entreprise avait pourtant recruté une
centaine de salariés à mon après avoir
décroché en 2021 un contrat avec moderna
pour le conditionnement du vaccin
antiovid mais depuis ce marché décroit
faute de commande les salariés ont déjà
été contraints de travailler à temps
partiel et 95 postes postes ont été
supprimés en avril dernier des actions
qui n'ont pas permis de maintenir
l'activité du site Lesa
Turquier c'est officiel à mon récifarm
fermera ses portes d'ici 2 ans sans
aucun repreneur ce sont plus de 220
postes supprimés ce mercredi matin la
nouvelle a déjà fait le tour de la ville
c'est pas la première fois que monstre
prend une mauvaise nouvelle voilà quoi
donc c'est c'est dommage que il y ait
pas plus d'anticipation que ça de la
part des groupes pharmaceutiques c'est
toujours des de voir que encore 200
personnes vont être encore au chômage
aujourd'hui et que autour de Mont
Vignier mon Bason tout ferme quoi
malheureusement la direction du groupe
pharmaceutique a annoncé une cessation
d'activité à partir du printemps 2025 am
mon réci farm a déjà fait l'objet d'une
rupture de convention collective en
avril dernier synonyme de 95 départs
volontaires au sein de l'entreprise pour
les salariés l'annonce a eu l'effet d'un
électrochoc c'est un choix du conseil
d'administration et visiblement ferme
aujourd'hui on s'attendait pas à ça
après une RCC pour justement redynamiser
l'entreprise repartait la production la
qualité tout le monde avait repris le
bon le bon sens donc clairement c'est un
choc pour tous les salariés entre 2021
et 2022 ici ont été produits 70 millions
de doses de vaccins anti covid la
société a même été soutenue par l'État à
hauteur de 35 millions d'euros pour le
lancement d'une nouvelle chaîne de
production depuis les besoins en vaccin
ont diminué peu à peu entraînant une
baisse d'activité générale aujourd'hui
seul espoir des salariés l'arrivée d'un
repreneur pour conserver leur emploi
nous avons pris comme un véritable
percute le bassin pharmaceutique
tourangeau ne serait pas capable
d'absorber l'ensemble des salariés de
réifarmement on serait obligé de
d'envisager des des reconversions
professionnelles il y a des personnes et
des mères de famille on a des familles
ici cependant si un repreneur vient on
est prêt à se relever les manches
vraiment tous ensemble
la direction n'a pas souhaité répondre à
nos sollicitations le groupe suédois
réfarm compte 4 sites en France pour un
millier de
salariés